Hello folks, how are you? Welcome back.
I hope you're having a wonderful day.
I am being
blessed with such wonderful weather here
locally and just a carnival-like
atmosphere
on my Twitter account today.
>> [laughter]
>> So, anyway,
uh we're going to take a quick look at
today.
Uh today was CPI.
And early this morning I was counseling
you all
to try to avoid
becoming insolvent
trying to predict what the CPI was going
to do beforehand.
It's always beneficial for it to try to
run, let it
take off,
and whatever it does,
going moving higher or lower,
uh we can then usually
fade that type of thing.
Uh it can be a
two-stage delivery, kind of like a FOMC.
Uh the only problem is is
if it's part of a trending run,
that two-stage won't be there. It'll
just keep going and it'll be a day where
it's just one-sided,
and unless you were in it ahead of time,
which is always a gamble,
you probably don't get to participate in
that.
Okay? So, because we're in a range-bound
environment,
uh today was a pretty
pretty easy trade
after CPI and after we got into 10:00.
Okay? So, you had to wait, give it a
little bit of time,
and I'll go over some of the things, but
I want to counsel you to go look at
yesterday's
lunch
time period, and I taught this in my
mentorship here.
If you look at the
vertical line here, that's 10:00 in the
morning Eastern Time yesterday,
and
1:30 p.m. Eastern Time yesterday. So,
New York lunch
is a 2-hour window of time.
We had relatively equal highs here
in the afternoon going into 1:31 New
York lunch ends.
And then the opening range for p.m.
session begins
until 2:00 Eastern time. That's what
this is here. Okay?
But, I want you to take a look at how
this buy side
was taken ahead of
the 1:30 close
on New York lunch.
That's not random.
Okay? So, this run on buy side liquidity
prior to that happening
go right into this candlestick right
there.
That is a buy side imbalance sell side
inefficiency
right before the liquidity was taken
during
New York lunch.
So, this is an algorithmic price
delivery.
It's not buying pressure.
Just as much as it's not selling
pressure to drove it down.
This individual candlestick, now look at
look at the data up here, okay? We're
going to be looking at the closing
price, which is this right there
on this candlestick. Notice that price.
25,165
.75
The next candlestick's open
needs to be
higher
of a close
I'm sorry, higher higher opening price
rather than this candlestick's close.
So, anything like 25,166
even or higher
would warrant
annotating this with a
volume imbalance.
Here's the opening price. So, it's
25,1
166 even. So, you have to anchor to this
candlestick's close.
Which is 25,165
and 3/4.
And that's what you see the anchor to,
okay?
The candlestick low here
25,177
and 1/2.
So that is your
buy side imbalance sell side
inefficiency with a volume imbalance at
the low, okay?
So here
if this was bullish, one would expect it
to trade down into and go higher.
Not at this time of day.
It's going to go back and seek
liquidity.
What liquidity? What's it going to look
for?
You got to go back and consider
at 10:00
start going through here is a sell side
liquidity pool. There's a sell side
liquidity pool and it's part of first
instance of a fair value gap, which is
that darker red line. And you have this
as well.
Okay? So you have several factors we can
use
the retracement lower in PM session.
Between
these two vertical lines, that is the
opening range
for PM trading in
indices.
1:30 Eastern time to 2:00
p.m. Eastern time.
First instance of a fair value gap here.
Displacement.
Trades up into it. There you go. First
instance of a fair value gap.
Shorting.
Hits it here.
This buy side imbalance sell side
inefficiency is now changing its
characteristic to
inversion fair value gap.
It dumps aggressively into first
instance of a fair value gap. Look at
the bodies respecting it. It's It's
probably random.
Trades up into consequent encroachment
of the city with the volume balance.
Midpoint, bodies respecting it,
consequent encroachment. Trades lower
down into
regular trading hours opening range gap
low
for yesterday. You see a trade in here,
look at that reaction there. Then trades
down into
this inefficiency. I told you that we
would [clears throat] see it act as an
inversion.
And beautiful delivery to consequent
encroachment and then sends it up into
efficiency there.
And we go into new start of new day with
electronic trading hours. So now what
I'm going to do is I'm going to take
this here
and I'm going to extend it to the right.
Okay, so
mind the price levels here. 25,177 1/2
25,165
3/4.
It's part of this
lunchtime
reversal.
So we're not looking at a classic here's
an old high, let's put a line on it
that's a support resistance. Here's a
classic high, let's put a trend line on
it and call it resistance.
That's not what we're doing here, okay?
We're not doing it with that high, we're
doing it with the inefficiency that sets
the tone for a reversal at the time of
the New York lunch closing.
Everything in here sets the stage for
revisiting these specific PD arrays.
This one here
starts with a busy
turns to an inversion fair value gap.
So price trading up to this
is a reason to anticipate lower prices.
So now we're going to go in
move forward in time.
See what price did
overnight
using yesterday's
opening range gap
over the trading hours.
Okay, and then at
8:30, we had CPI, which was kind of
wonky.
Trades down into this
old order flow there.
Price back inside of
Tuesday's regular trading hours opening
range gap.
I told you to
monitor that today, and also keep your
eye on
24,892
sell side.
Okay? So,
price trades up
here.
There's that inefficiency
from yesterday's
lunch
New York lunch 2-hour window the buy
side was tagged and and rated.
There was a two price points I told you
to be mindful of.
And it runs up into it. Look at the Look
at the body stop right here. And then
opens, trades just a little bit outside
of it, and then collapses.
That's a wonderful opportunity to get in
sync with the market on a
complex reversal. Okay, so um it's very
scary to take these trades when you
don't know what you're doing. And I'm
not trying to indicate that you should
be doing it. I'm just showcasing
prowess, skill,
foresight,
the idea of knowing what it's likely to
do.
Cuz I've come out here before many times
and I've said, when I was doing just
forex education,
I I knew where the high and lows are.
Okay. And I know it And it sounded It
sounded crazy, but I've done it many
times. I've done it with executions.
I've done it with
demo accounts, live accounts. I've done
it with paper trading. I've done it with
tape reading. I've done it with analysis
that eventually
comes to fruition the next day.
The next several days.
Okay?
Week after week, it was like this for
years.
And
I want to kind of like want to bring
something to light cuz I said I would
teach something.
Uh yesterday I was in the trade round up
uh one of the chartered membership
students that I have
asked if I would be teaching new PD
array. And I said I'd be releasing two
of them this year. And one of them is
this one here. When you're
utilizing the
2-hour lunch window
previous day
if you have a reversal after liquidity's
been taken
you take that
inefficiency right before it takes the
liquidity
carry that forward
into the next day.
If it trades up into it
it can set the tone for a shorting
opportunity. Reverse it for going long.
Now, let's look at the the mechanics of
what
the price action was doing leading up to
this.
CPI number, back and forth, okay? And
then we went a little bit lower.
The 24,892 and 1/2 level didn't get
traded to here. Came up into Tuesday's
regular trading hours opening range gap.
I do not have today's opening range
annotated. I did not need it.
Using just yesterday's opening range
gap is sufficient enough and this is the
consequent encroachment level of that or
midpoint. So, look at the bodies
respecting it here and here. You don't
think there's no algorithm?
>> [sighs]
>> Trades up, hits the high of the here
creates a buy side imbalance sell side
inefficiency
which will later become an inversion
fair value gap.
On my phone, I had these drawn as two
lines, okay? But
for the purpose of making it much more
prominent on the recording here, I
changed it to
a rectangle so that way you can see it a
little bit better.
It was real thin lines and if you look
at the posts I did on X, you'll see that
these were just simply too thin
uh trend line rays. And these are the
two darker ones that were in the video.
Then we have another buy side imbalance
sell side inefficiency that should act
as inversion as well. Why? Because it's
going to go up
here, this short-term high forms right
at 9:42.
And now we're going to be entering
that gap here, which is
is going to offer discount sensitivity
first.
Hits it here, rallies, comes back up
into this buy side imbalance sell side
inefficiency. So this is reclaimed
bullish fair value gap
there.
This one here also nests together.
And you have an inversion fair value gap
between here. So that's a very, very
strong. That's why you got that big pop
Okay?
Price runs right up into my level, what
I'm looking for.
And it's above this high here. So we
have turtle soup scenario.
Nobody
nobody, okay? Nobody was picking this
price.
Okay?
I can say that cuz
I'm Mr. Nobody.
Price trades into it here and then sells
off. Now this little area right in here
I had on the lower time frames, it's an
inversion fair value gap. I'm not going
to change the chart here cuz I want to
keep my notes on the lower time frames
germane to what I want to use for
tomorrow.
But this is anchored to smaller time
frame
sub 1 minute.
If you were using it on this 1 minute
time frame, you would just be simply
anchoring it to this candlesticks
high
to that candlesticks low and you'd still
be fine. Okay? But, I'm using a very
small time frame model,
and it afforded me the idea of looking
for this, and then when it traded up in
here and you'll see I'll I'll show you
the executions in a moment. But, this is
inversion fair value gap. Now, I went
short, again added pyramiding it.
And then, price meandered back down into
yesterday, Tuesday's regular trading
hours opening range gap.
Now, the draw
was
24,892
even.
So, look at the tweet.
Look what I posted this morning on the
X.
This was those relative equal lows that
we were watching that I told you in
yesterday's stream that it would not go
below.
And it didn't.
Here, it only went down below this.
Look at the low right here.
You're looking at the low price right up
here, upper left-hand corner where my
mouse is pointing. That's the low.
If you look at that candlestick right
there,
24,892
even.
So, it went
just two ticks below
the level that was defined from
yesterday's pre-market session. So,
before 9:00 in the morning Eastern time.
So, that was the the liquidity.
I had to leave the house for a little
bit, and I unfortunately I couldn't
manage the trade. And I I wanted to do
something like this.
If you look a little bit lower, there's
this liquidity pool down here.
Now, scratch it out so you can see it.
Right there. That's that low there. I
was going to try to aim for that.
But,
I wanted to first see if it could get
down into
uh event horizon. So, let me let me give
you an illustration of what event
horizon is. Again, this is not something
anyone has in their books, okay? No one
taught this stuff. I didn't learn it
from anybody on this planet, okay? So,
here's 892 half. So, we're going to
anchor it to 892 half.
Drag down to 54 quarter.
Go on here and
make sure it's on it. 54 quarter.
92 half, okay?
And I have it set just to show the 50%
level. So, that's event horizon. Okay,
so it's the middle point between two
pools of liquidity.
So,
when it was trading here, I I could have
very easily closed the trade and been,
"Yay, look how smart I am." Okay?
But, I wanted to stay with it, but I had
an errand pop up un-
scheduled. My wife said I had to take
care of something and
you know how it is, guys. You know, it's
just
honey do. That's what it is. Honey do
lists, okay?
I'm not exempt from it. So,
I wanted to keep the stop loss above the
high up here. I didn't want to do
anything with it and just let it go
and try to get an attempt to get down to
event horizon and then roll the stop
just above this
pool of liquidity and then maybe see if
I can get that or get stopped out, still
in close proximity to 24 892 and a half.
And that would have been enough, you
know, for you know, government work.
But, I had to close it and show me I
showed you on rather X I logged in.
X posted the video of me closing the
position saying, you know, I can't
manage it right now. You can see where
my stop loss was. You can see where the
levels were, what I was aiming for. I
had a limit order down here and I'm
telling you how I would have managed it.
And it wasn't until it got back up into
this
buy side and efficiency. Now, post
New York lunch, again, same thing here.
Here is 1:30 Eastern time.
And what is it doing? It's trading right
up into that
gap that becomes inversion fair value
gap. And then it dives right down into
what's what's this candlestick's low
right here.
Look at that price.
24,873.75
This price comes in
on all time highs here.
24,873
and a quarter.
So, it's slightly higher, but it's
drawing towards that midpoint, okay?
And
since then, we've just been just
meandering back inside of Tuesday's
regular trading hours opening range gap.
So, I was not able to take
this.
I was commuting back to the house, and
the sell side below here just it was so
obvious. So many So many lows there
just kept uh
presenting itself.
And
if you look at price like this, okay?
What do you see?
What do you you see here?
Take this wick out for a moment, okay?
Just imagine that wick is not there.
Do you see original consolidation?
Accumulation?
Reaccumulation?
Smart money reversal?
Low risk sell?
First stage distribution?
Second stage distribution?
In a rarity, when it affords it, it'll
give you one more distribution to take
out the original consolidation to a
level I told you it was going to go to.
Now,
I already outlined in this lecture what
this is, okay?
It's yesterday's New York lunch when
they ran buy side. When the buy side's
taken, you look for the inefficiency
right before the liquidity's taken.
That's how you're picking it. You're not
picking the fair value gap right before
that one cuz it's one slightly one
candle before that one I highlighted.
You're picking the one that's formed
right before the liquidity's taken.
Because it's part of a
complex reversal, part of a
macro time.
It's during a
New York session
lunch yesterday.
And it's happening at a time when
reversals take place.
So, instead of looking at classic
support resistance ideas, which is what
I do not do,
I'm going in and I'm finding exactly
what the algorithm is going to go right
back up to that reprice. And that's the
end of the show after that. Then lower,
lower, lower, lower.
So,
if we look at the uh
executions,
I'm inside that
fair value gap right here.
There.
On the down close candle. So, it went up
and on the way down, I'm shorting it,
okay? On the way down.
No heat. Zero heat. Nada. None. Zilch.
Trades down, goes into the inversion
fair value gap.
Sells off and then I'm trading watch.
Look close. Look at Look where it ends
up. Ready? And boop. See that? Look at
that. Look. See? Look at that.
>> [laughter]
>> What a guy. That guy, ICT. well, he gets
really lucky around here.
He gets so lucky all the time, son of a
But, he runs and drops back down
into Tuesday
regular trading hours opening range gap.
And I'm getting rid of the high. You see
that? Perfect. See that? Perfect. Not
some random a bunch of arrows all over
the place. You have no idea why they're
doing what they're doing. Okay? I teach
a I teach a theory. I teach you a
concept. I teach you a structure. I
teach you algorithmic principles.
How to get in, how to get out. Okay?
You're seeing my executions exactly
on that premise.
Not willy-nilly stuff. Not some Well, I
hope it I hope I can chase price up here
or chase price down here. No, I know
exactly what I'm looking for like a
highly trained sniper.
Okay? That's the difference. That's the
difference.
So,
I took one of the only two contracts.
Now, I get it. I get it. I get it. Dude,
bro, you're brand new. You haven't been
around here for a while. And you're
looking up here and you're saying,
"Dude, it's a micro.
It's only $2 a point. Why don't you
trade size?" Cuz I'm teaching people
that don't have a lot of money that you
can do well
with just one micro.
Just one micro.
And now I'm showing you once you get to
the point where you can afford to have
one more micro in your trading,
this is how you can apply it. Now,
the market trades down, goes just below
the liquidity pool at uh 24,892 half by
going to
892 even.
So, it technically goes below that low.
I wanted to see it go down to at least
event horizon between
the next pool of liquidity here and
here. I wanted to see that. But, you
watch me close the trade out and it's
trading right here at near the low of
Tuesday's regular trading hours opening
range gap.
Okay?
After that,
them's the breaks. No other executions
that I can, you know, attribute to,
"Hey, I did something wonderful."
I stuck to do things I told you I was
going to do today.
I'm not looking for
um
I'm personally not looking for longs.
I I'd rather look for shorts because I I
think they're going to let it release.
Then it's going to happen where it's
just totally unexpected. It's going to
be a sudden type thing. So, I'd rather
be
hunting those scenarios where I can
hopefully catch that tiger by the tail
when it starts ripping and running.
The only problem is, and this is the
the thing I mentioned today, you why I
get question all the time, why do I
believe that the market's being held in
consolidation? Like, what's making it so
hard to move out of that big daily
range?
If you do some research, you'll see that
there is a historic
holding of put options right now
on stocks and stock index futures.
So, what is what is the the majority
betting on?
Think about that analogy I talked about
before, when the riverboat casinos in
the old days, going up and down the
Mississippi River.
The roulette table would be rigged
and they had three paddles
that were ran by magnets.
And inside the ball
would be a polarized magnet, north or
south, doesn't matter which one it was.
But, underneath the numbers on the
wheel,
there would be paddles that would be
electronically driven. And the operator
at the table would put his foot on the
pedal for black
if he wanted to make sure black came up.
So, the magnets would come up, making
sure that everything
but
the the black would have a
same polarity
as the ball that would go around the
wheel. So, when the when the ball
finally settles, it can only fall into a
number slot that allows it to.
So, if there's a magnet on every other
number,
including green,
see, you're not looking for these types
of things, but that's how it was rigged.
It would fall in with the majority
would
be as it as the take
or the profit for the operator or the
casino.
Okay, the riverboat casino would would
make the majority of the money on the
table. So, that's what they do. They
they they rig it in a way where
somebody's going to win. And that's what
gets people betting. So, the operator
needs to go through and scan across the
table and get a feel for how much money
is on the table being bet.
And the majority of if it's
red
or black,
he's going to make it come
where it's the outcome that's beneficial
for the house to get the majority. But
if he can't or she can't determine what
that amount of money is,
all they have to do is make green come
up, and he they get to take both red and
black off the table.
So, it kind of like breaks them.
>> [sighs]
>> So,
I said all that
really to just kind of like build the
idea that I think what they're doing is
is they're holding the stock market up
because there's a lot of people that
would be making lots and lots of money
holding heavy short positions because
they think it's Armageddon financially,
everything's going to collapse, and
I believe that's going to happen
eventually,
but right now, they got to get through
option expiration.
Okay, and I think what'll happen is
we'll probably see markets start to
loosen up a little bit more after triple
witching. And triple witching is
usually when the contract expires, you
hear there's a whole lot of release and
roll over going into the next month, but
you also see a little bit more price
action smoothing.
So, I think that's what we're we're
waiting for.
And uh until that happens, we're
probably going to have to stay in this
range.
And then it'll be interesting to see
also what uh what silver does because
I'm really
I'm really watching that one. Not cuz
I'm trading it. I don't want to be in
it, but I'm I'm a little
suspicious as to what's going to happen
in that particular market. If you've
been following it any length of time or
listen to the trader round up spaces,
you kind of know what I'm expecting
there. Okay? So,
hopefully you found this one insightful.
Hope it gets your gears going. Go back
through your old price action and look
at that 2-hour lunch period and when
there is a
turtle soup
short or long,
find that first fair value gap right
before the liquidity is taken. Carry
that over to the next day. If it trades
up in there, you're going to get many
times the high or low of the day.
Don't take my word for it. Till next
time, wish good luck and good trading.